hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over a tactic that everyone
needs to have in the repertoire it is
the concept of Attraction trying to
attract your opponent's pieces to a
particular Square so you can have a
strong attack now usually you're going
to be sacrificing a material to attract
your opponent's king or their Queen to a
specific Square so we're going to go
over some examples so you have an idea
of what that looks like it's White's
move and white if you look at some of
the opportunities that they have one of
those is to play Knight to D7 now when
they play Knight to D7 you can see that
the Knight is attacking the B6 square
and the f8 square so this is forking the
queen and this f8 Square unfortunately
Black's king is not on f8 it is on G8 so
in a best case scenario if we could
attract the king to the f8 square we
would have the opportunity to play
Knight to D7 so we need to be looking
for ways to get our opponent to move to
the square we want them to to attract
them to that square luckily we have the
move Rook 2 f8 you can see that black
does not have any other option except
for the king to take here on f8 so while
white is sacrificing material
this move should allow them to gain
material or gain an advantage in the
game and that's exactly what this does
white sacrifices a rook and they're able
to play Knight to D7 check forking the
king and the Queen
after the king moves probably to E7
centralizing as much as possible white
can take on B6 capture the queen and
should have a pretty pretty easy in-game
let's look at another example with a
similar concept and then we'll look at
some more advanced variations to make
sure that we can drill in the concepts
we're looking at so it's Black's move
and see if you can find the best move
for attraction
now the move in this particular spot is
Rook to H1 similar to the previous
position we looked at black would really
like to play Knight takes on G3
attacking the queen on H5
but the king is on H2 right now the king
could just take on G3 and everything's
fine but really black would be in a
better position if the king were on H1
and so black can sacrifice the rook and
attract the king from H2 down to H1 and
take that Rook now white doesn't have to
take the Rook they could play an even
worse move and just come to G2 and not
even take the rook and then they're just
down even more material but they're
essentially forced and attracted to the
H1 Square by the rook and now black can
come in take on G3 with fork and then
after the king moves they can capture
this queen on H5 now white does have the
Rook but white cannot capture this
Knight on G3 because this Rook is pinned
down by the queen on C6 so in this spot
while it does look like they can
recapture they're actually in a fork and
they're going to lose their Queen so
that's the second example let's look at
some more advanced variations
let's look at another example and first
we have to analyze the position and see
what threats white has and where black
can go from here
now if you look at White's Bishop it's
blocking off these two squares right
here for the king
then if you look at this Square on C5
that's blocked off by The Pawn on D4 so
see if you can find a way that white can
attract black to a specific square and
then use that for an advantage
hopefully you were able to find the move
Queen takes on D5 now we already looked
at the bishop taking off these squares
the queen also takes off the B7 square
and the C5 Square was already blocked
off by The Pawn on D4 so the king is
essentially forced and is attracted to
the D5 Square
and now white has mate in one with
Bishop to E4
let's go and take a look at another
example
one of the most satisfying uses of
Attraction comes in the smothered mate
it's White's move you can tell they're
down quite a bit in material but they
have the move Queen to G8 now in this
case we're not trying to attract the
king to G8 that would be an illegal move
because that score is actually defended
or attacked by the Knight on H6 instead
we're attracting The Rook on f8 to come
to G8 that's the only legal move that
black has so we're attracting The Rook
to G8 but now that opens up the door for
Knight to F7
and this is Checkmate we attracted The
Rook to G8 and forced black to trap
their own King on h8 which allows us to
play smothered mate with Knight to F7 so
let's look at one more example to make
sure everyone understands truly how to
identify attraction in their own games
the last example we're going to look at
it's White's move so take a minute and
see if you can find the best option
now white should play Rook takes on G7
we're attracting the king to G7 Black's
in a world of hurt regardless of how
they play but if they don't take on G7
because they're not always forced to go
to the square you're attracting them to
but usually they're in an even worse off
position if they don't because if they
just go f8 well then they lose to
Checkmate if they come to h8 then they
lose to Checkmate here on H7 so we're
attracting them to the G7 Square
but then white has Rook to F7
check and is defended by the bishop on
C4 and after they move it doesn't matter
if they come to h8 or G8 both of those
options are going to be followed up by
Queen two H seven
so this is attracting getting your
opponent to move to squares where you
want them to so when you're analyzing
your own games try to think about the
best case if my opponent had pieces on
particular squares what that would do
for you in your position and then see if
you can actually force them to go to
those squares hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video I'll see you guys in the next
one